ja ich weiß das sieht nicht so aus aber
das hier ist tatsächlich ein Bahnhof
genauer gesagt der höchste Bahnhof
Europas Jungfraujoch ja sehr
interessanter Name liegt an der Jungfrau
das ist ein Berg der ist seiner Nähe der
Bahnhof befindet sich auf ca 3.500 m
über dem Meeresspiegel also wirklich
ziemlich hoch ich war ja letztens in der
Schweiz und ich habe schon einige Videos
dazu gesehen und ich wollte da unbedingt
mal hin und konnte dann zum Glück mein
Kumpel Loris dazu überreden ein Ausflug
dahin zu machen deswegen schauen wir uns
im heutigen Video mal diesen Bahnhof ein
bisschen genauer an let's go hey Leute
was geht ab und herzlich Willkommen zu
meinem Video ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht es gut ich begrüße euch heute
morgen aus der Schweiz wir sind hier
nämlich im wunderschönen Orten alle
Schweizer einmal den Daumen nach oben
drücken und
ich bin heute nicht alleine unterwegs
hallo komm jetzt
ja ich bin heute nicht allein unterwegs
der Loris ist auch dabei alles fresh ja
sehr gut geschlafen gut ausgeschlafen
gut ausgeschlafen wir haben heute was
richtig geiles vor ich freue mich
unfassbar denn wir fahren heute nicht
zum höchsten Bahnhof Deutschlands der
ist nämlich 400 m hoch und in Berlin
Spandau habe ich gerade erfahren auch
nicht wirklich das ist wirklich so nein
doch Vorsicht gelb ich habe mich
übrigens vertan der höchste Bahnhof ist
Feldberg Bärental auf 967 m und ja
Berlin Spandau ist der längste Bahnhof
da habe ich irgendwas durcheinander
gebracht wir fahren
wir fahren auch nicht zum höchsten
Bahnhof der Welt der ist ziemlich in
tangula in China und auf über 5000
Metern wir fahren heute zum höchsten
Bahnhof Europas in Jungfrau noch
Jungfraujoch Jungfraujoch ach so ja
meine ich ja genau das ist der Bahnhof
in der Schweiz und du warst doch schon
mal ne ja und spektakulär ähm ja schon
äh also vor allem für Touristen für die
Schweiz ist es so mittlerweile wie
normal
ich bin halt kein Schweizer deswegen
freue ich mich sehr und ich glaube das
wird ein richtig geiler Tag heute ich
freue mich man muss einfach sagen ich
weiß unfassbar schön und ja let's go
also ihr habt sie schon wirklich sehr
sehr gut als Schweizer wenn man also bis
auf die Baustelle halt jetzt so was sagt
man auf schweizerisch wenn so so
verdammt was heißt auf schweizerisch
oh verdammt so wir holen jetzt hier
erstmal noch in irgend so eine Gemeinde
mein Ticket ab los hat das organisiert
damit ich nicht 200 € bezahlen muss ne
eine Tageskarte also manchmal komme ich
auch gar nicht drauf klar was hier bei
euch in der Schweiz möglich ist naja
kannst du mal den Zuschauern kurz
erklären wo wir jetzt als erstes
hinfahren fahren
bis nach Interlaken Ost ich glaube es
ist etwas ne Stunde bisschen mehr als
eine Stunde und dann geht's nach
Grindelwald von da aus nehmen wir glaube
ich einige Express und dann sind wir
schon fast auf Jungfrauen müssen wir
nicht auch Gondel fahren glaube ja ich
bin noch nicht ganz sicher ich glaube
aber das ist jetzt der erste Zug let's
go
[Musik]
ich finde echt lustig ja und dann bist
Du
glaube ich nicht so lustig an meine
Zuschauerschaft aber trotzdem nein ich
bin durch jetzt auch mal unseren
Fahrplan ein wir fahren heute drei
Stunden 13 müssen dreimal umsteigen und
dann sind wir in Jungfrau Loch
also als Deutscher ist man wirklich
neidisch auf eure Landschaft die das ist
ja geisteskrank Alter guck mal da vorne
mein lieber Herr Gesangsverein
[Musik]
so Leute das hier ist jetzt unser
nächster Zug bzw der da hinten wir
müssen nicht nach Lauterbrunnen sondern
nach Grindelwald Grindelwald hey los wie
kann es denn sein dass der zu 3 Minuten
Verspätung hat also das habe ich ein
Deutschland noch nie gesehen ja jede
Schweiz ist kein Spaß jedesmal so was 3
Minuten Verspätung schon wieder die SPD
und pünktlich und zufällig ich denke wir
waren noch nie in Deutschland ne
also das muss man wirklich sagen bei
euch in der Schweiz ich finde Zug von
hier ist ein richtiges Erlebnis in
Deutschland denke ich mir nach Borg gar
kein Bock ich muss morgen wieder zu
fahren in der Schweiz kann man sich
darüber freuen warum meinst ja wegen der
Landschaft und so keine Ahnung das ist
hier ein ganz anderes Feeling ja na ja
jetzt kann noch mal krass sein
ich hoffe sehr ich hoffe ich bin
gespannt Leute und wir sehen uns
nächster Zug steht an
[Musik]
dieser Zeit fährt weiter nach
Grindelwald
nach Lauterbrunnen
[Musik]
ist immer
so Leute mittlerweile angekommen hier
bei der Gondelbahn richtig wir fahren
jetzt mit der Gondel noch ein Stück hoch
und dann fahren wir mit Zug wieder ne
genau Alter ja wirklich crazy muss sagen
auch hier sieht schon super aus weißt du
wie hoch z.B jetzt dieser Berg da oben
ist ich weiß nicht genau wie hoch aber
wir fahren ja noch hören ne ich muss
gerade überlegen ob das glaube ich die
eigene Nordbahn also Leute ab in die
Gondel und wir sind aber immer noch eine
Stunde unterwegs also das ist echt noch
ein Stückchen obwohl wir schon mit dem
Bergen sind
zusammen okay
[Gelächter]
ich werde noch arm hier bei dir in der
Schweiz das ist ja unfassbar wir können
jetzt wenigstens da rein laufen
[Musik]
günstiger
also Leute wir singen können wir haben
leider nicht ganz so gutes Wetter aber
ich bin hier Du bist da mein
Sonnenschein
wirklich wir haben jetzt einfach für
diese hochfahrt bis zur Jungfrau Station
164 Schweizer Franken bezahlen Digger
davon lebe ich eine Woche in Deutschland
also für die die da wirklich hochfahren
wollen überlegt euch weil das ist teuer
auch wenn ich jetzt nicht los gehabt
hätte ich hätte mir auch einen Pass
kaufen müssen für die Züge wie viel wäre
das ungefähr gewesen
[Musik]
okay Leute wir haben es fast geschafft
werkstation der Gondel und hier fährt
jetzt ein Zug das muss man sich mal
vorstellen hier fährt ein Zug aber mal
Ticket
okay ab und Zug fahren wir bis da ganz
oben man sieht der ganze um links die
letzte Fahrt mit der Jungfrau Bahn bis
zum top of Europe dauert dann noch
ungefähr so 20 Minuten das ist aber echt
nicht spektakulär man fährt halt die
ganze Zeit nur durch den Tunnel bzw
durch den Berg und ja es ist halt durch
den dunkel man kann das gar nicht
erkennen auf der Kamera aber hier geht's
auf jeden Fall jetzt extrem steil berg
hoch das ist eigentlich wie so eine
Achterbahn diese hochgezogen wird muss
ich hier richtig abstützen damit ich
nicht so runter Rutsche achtet mal
darauf wie schlägt der steht dann ist
uns noch aufgefallen dass wir gar keine
Handschuhe dabei hatten weil oben war es
ja schon sehr sehr kalt ich glaube
ungefähr - 20 Grad an dem Tag
140 €
wahrscheinlich
gefahren aber egal wir sind jetzt auf
3500 Metern
ich finde man merkt ein bisschen dass
hier die Luft dünner ist oder ja also
ich bin direkt außer acht ein bisschen
Kopfschmerzen
oben angekommen ist mir aufgefallen dass
es in diesem Bahnhof gar keinen
Starbucks kein Pizza hat nichts gibt
also total komisch wir gehen jetzt
gerade hier auf den Top und ich muss
sagen mir ist echt schwindelig ey das
hatte ich noch nie ich kann eigentlich
alles ab ich habe keine Höhenangst gar
nichts
boah
ja dann könnten wir auf jeden Fall noch
diesen Aufzug hier nehmen der uns noch
mal ungefähr 120 m weiter nach oben
gebracht hat das ist dann diese
Aussichtsplattform die man auch von den
Fotos kennt und ja da wollten wir
natürlich hin
hier kann man eine Rolex kaufen
dass er wieder typisch Schweiz okay
Leute nach über drei Stunden haben wir
es fast geschafft hier geht's jetzt nach
draußen Alter ich gebe es wirklich
schwindelig ob man es glaubt oder nicht
kommen sie kommen sie yay
kalt
das wieder rein wow
boah das ist wirklich hoch wäre cool
wenn die Kamera nicht runterfällt
wir haben hier oben auf jeden Fall
gerade fast minus 20 Grad und der Wind
ist brutal Alter und hier geht's noch
runter aber leider kann man da nicht
rumgehen das hier ist auf jeden Fall der
Bahnhof ich bin froh dass ich jetzt
einmal hier war aber ja die Sicht heute
ist halt nicht so krass los können wir
wieder reingehen mir ist kalt
von dem top top of Europe weiter nach
unten und das war knapp und da konnte
man dann noch durch so einen schönen
Glaspalast gehen wir hier gleich sehen
werdet das war auch ganz entspannt oh
vorsichtig
also hier gibt es auf jeden Fall auch so
ein Eispalast den wir jetzt gerade hier
palazieren
hallo
[Musik]
sorry
ich muss sagen das war wirklich ein sehr
sehr ereignisreicher Tag mehr als
wirklich Spaß gemacht und ich kann hier
nur empfehlen da mal hinzufahren falls
ihr dafür keinen Kredit aufnehmen müsst
[Musik]
eine Sache die ich noch frage ich stelle
mich da jetzt nicht an aber warum wollen
die anderen Foto machen mit der Flagge
dann haben wir das jetzt auch toll und
jetzt ist es schnell was essen
Leute ich hoffe das Video hat Euch
gefallen ich mache noch eine kleine
Bewertung am Ende und ich mache das
jetzt einfach hier kommt vor würde ich
drei von fünf geben war jetzt schon ein
bisschen anstrengend der Ritt aber am
Ende hat sich definitiv gelohnt Essen
gab es nicht weit weg es gab es nicht
weit weg naturerlebnisfaktor wieder 55
Leistung ja zwei von fünf also das ist
schon Arsch teuer kommen wir am Ende auf
zehn von 15 möglichen Sternen aber es
lohnt sich schon also man muss es mal
gemacht haben wenn man hier in der Nähe
ist und würdest als Schweizer noch mal
machen äh nee also nee würde ich nicht
ich würde eher etwas tiefer gehen und
Snowboarden zu gehen oder Skifahren zu
gehen aber trotzdem so wie wie eine
Geschichte weiß man muss es auch ja
genau man muss es einmal gemacht haben
deswegen ich war jetzt hier ja und damit
abonniert den Kanal haut rein Leute ciao
[Musik]